[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم البدايه من اقليمي
كاراباخ وزاره الدفاع الازربيجانيه تعلن
توصل الى اتفاق بشان تعليق عملياتها
العسكريه في كاراباخ بشروط وهي القاء
الجماعات المسلحه لسلاح بالكامل ومغادره
القوات الارمنيه للاقليم جهتها اعلنت
سلطات
ارمنتها وافقت على مقترح بعثه السلام
الروسيه بوقف لاطلاق النار
الى تطورات كارثتي ليبيا والمغرب حيث
اعلنت السلطات الليبيه تقسيم مدينه درنه
حسب الاضرار التي لحقت بكل منطقه الى ثلاث
مناطق واخلاء السكان من الاحياء الاكثر
تضررا وفي المغرب العمليات تتسارع في
اقليم الحوز لاواء المنكوبين وفرق لانقاص
تواصل انتشار الجثث والبحث في اكثر
المناطق تضرع
تصعدون اسرائيليون مستمر في الضفه الغربيه
حيث ما زالت قوات الاحتلال تحاصر قريه
جلبون شرق جنين وتمنع سكانها من الدخول
والخروج كما طوقت منزل احمد ابو البهاء
احد قاده كتائب شهداء الاقصى بهدف اعتقاله
لكن فشلت العمليه عند اقتحامها للمنزل ولم
تجده واعتقلت والده وهددت عائلته بالتصفيه
اذا لم يسلم نفسه
في تصريح جديد مثير للجدل ايلون ماسك يدرس
اقتراحا بفرض رسوم شهريه على حسابات منصه
واعرض ماسك هذا المقترح خلال لقائه برئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو عندما
اثار الاخير مساله المنشورات المعاديه
للساميه على الانترنت وكيفيه مواجهتها
وقلم ماسك ان الرسوم الشهريه قد تكبح جيوش
الحسابات الالكترونيه الى اللقاء